the big story that is affecting millions
of americans right now the devastating
winter storm
[Music]
man not what i expected when i moved to
texas this is the fifth day without
power
i'm sitting in my trailer just trying to
keep it together
it's been crazy 45 minutes on the
power's on boom
45 minutes of power's off james van der
beek like so many others
just can't seem to get a break we are
now
without water the father of five moved
to texas after tough times in la
and now after the storm he was out
looking for wood to burn
in the lone star state texas is not uh
not used to this and therefore i'm
really not prepared for it actress and
reality star tammy roman broke down in
tears on location in atlanta
she struggled to stay hopeful after her
home in texas was destroyed
by water damage i know everybody
is going through something power was out
in texas for a half a million people
today
temperatures have been below freezing
since sunday for some parts of the
country
in nashville our rachel smith shoveled
her way out
slowly but surely and et's lauren zema
stranded i have been stuck here for days
unable to get a flight home but
luckily i've had electricity the real
housewives of dallas star stephanie
hallman
did not we had no power for
three days and our kitchen sink was
frozen
it's scary how unprepared we were so you
were literally
using a wood-burning fireplace going
old-school to stay warm yeah
yeah yeah we have one in our living room
and that was our our heat source yeah
and now beyonce is pitching in to help
her be good foundation
is providing urgent relief to her home
state
still a lot of celebs made the best of
it the bachelor's ali feditowski mano
used buckets to make sleds for her kids
and tim mcgraw posted this backyard view
of turkeys in the snow that somebody's
enjoying it